right now everyone's favorite developer
electronic arts is facing
three class action lawsuits with
hundreds of people involved
why well the lawsuits say that ea's
popular sports games
create an endless cycle of gambling
designed to get you to spend more
and more and more money the lawsuit also
says that ea isn't just
hiding this fact they've allegedly been
lying about it
for years
guys we are well on our way to 2 million
subscribers and we can't do without you
so scroll down and hit that subscribe
button and if you have a story idea for
us hit us up at tips at the score.com
so every year ea releases a new slate of
sports games
in every year people get pissed off
because
let's be honest from fifa to madden
these games are a glorified roster
update and when it comes to madden 21
people are so pissed off at ea they got
hashtag nfl
drop ea trending on twitter while the
backlash is
unfortunately not surprising it's not
the only problem ea is currently facing
they're battling three class action
lawsuits in court
back in august the first lawsuit was
filed in california by a guy named kevin
ramirez
who according to the lawsuit represents
more than a hundred other people
a second lawsuit was filed in october
this time in canada
and that was quickly followed up in
november by another lawsuit again
based in the states at the heart of the
complaints in the lawsuits are loot
boxes
in a concept called dynamic difficulty
adjustment
each lawsuit states that ea games in
general not just their sports games
are filled with loot boxes that amount
to nothing more than gambling on top of
that the lawsuits
state in their own way that ea creates a
perpetual non-stop cycle of gambling
by using that concept of dynamic
difficulty adjustment that i talked
about earlier
and i'll explain what that means in just
a second and that's how a class action
lawsuit works
hundreds if not thousands of people have
the same complaint often against a
specific company
a giant lawsuit is filed and then one
person
represents the collective in court now
most of you already know what a loot box
is
those dumb crates you pay real money for
to open
in-game
the other thing that makes a loot box a
loot box is the element of chance
see each developer has their own
algorithms for creating different sets
of odds and then those
odds are assigned to a specific category
of loot box
the rarer the loot box the smaller the
chance you have to win some cool looking
[ __ ] i mean you get the point but here's
something important to keep in mind when
it comes to
madden and fifa which are the primary
focus of this video the most important
loot boxes in the game really
the only loot boxes in the game are
people well
players to be specific see these sports
specific loot boxes are connected to a
game mode called
ultimate team and every ea sports game
dating back to 2009 when ultimate team
was introduced
has a version of it madden ultimate team
fifa ultimate team you get
think of ultimate team as a ramped up
version of franchise mode where you take
a personalized team that you've created
play with them throughout the season and
make all the decisions a general manager
would but the difference with ultimate
team is that you build out a roster with
these player loot boxes in order to make
your team better for example you can
spend 14
actual dollars which gets you a hundred
thousand coins in matic
you then go into madden ultimate team
let's say spend 50
000 coins on an elite player pack that
gives you a tiny
chance to win patrick mahomes and then
you can use him as your starting
quarterback and if you don't care about
american football
just know you really want patrick
mahomes on your team's back
[Applause]
so much like case openings in cs go
you're essentially
gambling in ultimate team and we all
know how addictive case openings in cs
go can be
the difference here is that unlike cs go
with its case openings being based
purely around skins
these player packs can fundamentally
change your odds of winning
and so as all three lawsuits point out
not only does ea's loot boxes keep
players engaged for longer
but encourages addictive and potentially
negative gambling habits
quote loot boxes are considered part of
the compulsion loop of game design to
keep players invested in a game such
compulsion loops are known to contribute
towards video game addiction
and are frequently compared to gambling
addiction this is in part due to the use
of variable rate reinforcement schedule
similar to how slot machines dole out
prizes and it is especially dangerous
for children
end quote alright that was loot boxes
now let's add in the dynamic difficulty
adjustment concept that i mentioned
earlier from here on out i'm just going
to be calling it dda
because honestly that name sucks dda is
a behavioral design concept
think about it this way you know when
you're getting destroyed in madden
well in this case the ai difficulty
automatically adjusts to give you a
break
and vice versa when you're absolutely
crushing the competition
the difficulty automatically ramps up
this is all done behind the scenes via a
bunch of complex code that i don't
understand
there's never any indicator that it's
happening in front of you
and here's the crazy part for years now
ea has allegedly
denied that they use dda at all now you
might be
asking well why does ea need to deny
anything dda doesn't seem like that bad
of a thing but according to all three
lawsuits the concept of dda combined
with the loot box mechanics
creates a self-perpetuating cycle of
gambling
that ea never tells you about quote this
is a self-perpetuating cycle that
benefits ea to the detriment of ea
sports gamers
since difficulty adjusting mechanisms
make gamers believe their teams are less
skilled than they actually
are leading them to purchase additional
player packs in hopes of receiving
better players
and being more competitive end quote now
that statement comes from the second
us-based lawsuit filed in november and
what the statement is alleging there is
that dda is tricking players into
thinking they suck
incentivizing them into spending more
money on player packs
with the very very small chance of
buying a player
that would make all the difference on
the pitch gridiron or ice
guaranteed i have been on the receiving
end of the dynamic difficulty [ __ ]
because
i am trash at sports games but think
about it because your chances of winning
a superstar player are so low
you continue to suck you continue to buy
player packs and the cycle continues
now imagine how screwed up it would be
if the items you got from the cs go case
actually affected how you played on the
server like if a dragon lore skin
somehow made you 10 times better than if
you weren't using it
that's essentially what's happening with
these ea player packs now
how much money are we talking about here
how much money are people actually
spending on these things well according
to the second u.s
lawsuit in 2019 fifa pros competing in
the ultimate
team champions cup were using custom
built teams with quote
an average real world value of
approximately 27
000 end quote that was a thriller but
you got it done how are you able to keep
your edge
uh every game on fifa 20 is a 50 50.
like he'll win the next one i'll win
this one because the game is so like
unrewarding that anyone can win like
guys who aren't good can win people's
money and no one interested in it but
you know
we're here fans of fifa have long
theorized about the use of dba
in the game and multiple reddit
detectives have actually found mention
of it buried within ea's code
now back in 2017 ea basically denied the
existence of dba
but after multiple legal patents
surfaced online in 2019
listing ea as the legal rights holder to
dda
well fans were pissed and ea had to make
a statement quote
we've heard your concerns around the
dynamic difficulty adjustment patent
family
and wanted to confirm it's not used in
ea sports
fifa we would never use it to the
advantage or disadvantage of any group
of players against another
in any of our games the technology was
designed to explore how we might help
players that are having difficulty in a
certain area of the game
have an opportunity to advance end quote
and remember while ea
says that dda isn't being used in fifa
multiple chunks of all three lawsuits
state the exact opposite
they say that's not true and in fact dda
is being used in
all of their sports games and when it
comes to loot boxes ea has been facing
scrutiny for
years at this point from battlefield to
battlefront dragon age to the sims
ea has a terrible reputation when it
comes to loot boxes and wanting your
money on top of that
in october of this year a netherlands
based district court
actually ruled against ea when it comes
to the use of loot boxes in fifa
the court determined that those loot
boxes violates the country's gambling
and betting act now initially the courts
gave ea
an eight-week window in order to remove
or significantly alter those loot boxes
and escape monetary punishment but ea
basically said
nah we're good so the court slapped them
with a 10 million euro fine
now what's interesting to think about
with these legal battles is how they
could impact ea's esports scenes
remember in 2019 fifa pros were using
custom-built rosters that
on average we're worth 27 000
what happens if ea loot boxes get
severely altered
or banned entirely how are pro players
supposed to compete in a scene built
around buying loot boxes to make you
better if they're banned that's a giant
question ea might have to answer
depending on how these lawsuits go do i
see a world where loot boxes stop
existing hell no there's always going to
be an
in-game mechanism in place for companies
like ea to
separate you from your money but it's
possible based on recent government
rulings against
ea and the fact that three separate
class action lawsuits have made it to
court
that loot boxes and their alleged
negative gambling qualities could be
reined in
regulated or even banned entirely
and honestly that's a good enough place
to start
[Music]
those shiny crates light boxes are
filled with lot
jesus these shiny crates that i'm gonna
break this computer is
those shiny crates those obnoxiously
shiny cray